all right well last night's announcement
comes after a long sort of dance a long
process between the A's Las Vegas and
Oakland but in the end it seems like the
Bay Area just couldn't keep their team
Lauren negretti joining us live near
Dean Martin and Tropicana where that new
stadium will be reportedly built and I
thank Lauren we're going to be able to
pack that Stadium more than the A's have
as a plate
we'll see yeah big big sports fans out
here in Vegas that's for sure but yes
like he was saying they're right here
near where the old Wild Wild West
Gambling Hall was now right now over my
shoulder here doesn't look like much
doesn't look like a Major League
Baseball material but it won't be that
way for long soon it'll be transformed
into a billion dollar Stadium now moving
the Athletics to Las Vegas has been a
long process team leaders tried to get
Oakland to build a new stadium for the
club on the waterfront they couldn't get
a deal done same time the A's scouted
Las Vegas as a new home team officials
told the AP that the team finalized a
deal with Red Rock resorts for this land
last week the new stadium will be able
to hold 30 to 35
000 fans the Nevada independent reports
the A's will be footing the bill no
public money will be used last month we
spoke to the A's first baseman Kevin
Koran about the potential deal
I think that this is an awesome City and
um you know they really do a good
product here with an aviator so whatever
happens happens but you know it's it's
definitely a fun city to be in it's a
lively crowds and and it's it's uh you
know if that happens then then we'll be
happy to be here
the A's hope to break ground next year
hope to move into their new home by
2027. we don't know where they will be
playing uh while it's being constructed
here now the A's would really be the
only second MLB team in half a century
to be moving cities here of course our
sports team will have more on this
developing story later on today 4 8 news
now for now live near Dean Martin and
Tropicana Lauren negretti eight news now
the aviators out draw the the Oakland
A's I think there's more rats watching
the Oakland Athletics and people right
now well we've got a lot for the
aviators and speaking of of course there
are three other baseball teams out there
that have the minor league franchise
within the city so it's doable that's
right if that is the possibility thanks
Lauren appreciate it native